right now everybody is asking the
question is Marvel failing is Marvel
dying is Marvel done and some people out
there have already gone as far as
stating like it's a fact Marvel is done
Marvel is over but what if I told you
that if Marvel Studios just fixed one
main problem then nobody would be
thinking or stating this and the great
news is Marvel Studios knows this
problem and they are already trying to
fix it yes Marvel Studios has had a
rough go recently even I can admit that
the Miss Marvel series although very
very well liked among the fandom
unfortunately didn't perform very well
for views on Disney plus She-Hulk was
not really a success among the fandom
neither was Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania and then we had the secret
Invasion ending which really a lot of
the fandom did not like and
unfortunately people were already
talking poorly about the Marvels before
it even came out and then it did come
out and people are talking even more
poorly about the MCU right now more than
ever and even the major entertainment
Outlets are writing articles about the
future of Marvel Studios variety even
did what many people have called a
hitpiece on Marvel Studios about how
they were failing with the headline is
Marvel in trouble and this was before
the Marvel's came out and now that the
Marvel's is out and it's not performing
too well at the box office yet everybody
really is jumping on the train of Marvel
is in trouble what are they going to do
and people are genuinely concerned in
fact the Variety hitpiece article said
this Marvel is truly effed with the
whole Kang angle says one top dealmaker
who has seen the final Loki episode and
they haven't had an opportunity to
rewrite until very recently because of
the wga strike but I don't see a path to
how they move forward with him however
that did not end up being true also side
note that was very untrue it's actually
very easy to move forward right now with
Kang the finale for Loki season 2 really
set up King the Conqueror to be a huge
part of the Multiverse Saga like he's
supposed to be I don't know the main
villain or something I digress the truth
is Marvel has really one main problem
and if addressed and fixed would really
fix everything if they simply focused on
this before anything else and gave it
the top priority and this problem is the
writing this may seem like an obvious
problem but a lot of people do not
realize how much the writing affects
other things like the filming and the
visual effects here's the thing if you
fix the writing it pretty much
automatically fixes some other things as
well and drastically reduces problems
for movies and shows at Marvel Studios
we do have some great news though that
comes in the form of Loki season 2 that
will prove my entire point of the
writing being the main problem of the
MCU let me explain you see Loki season 2
did something that not a lot of Marvel
projects have done recently and that is
they finished the writing before they
filmed they did SC scrap one episode
episode 5 which they rewrote but they
rewrote this before they started filming
this really is a huge issue that Marvel
Studios tends to do a lot recently
fixing the writing and then combining
this with scaling back a bit on content
will Revitalize the MCU and Marvel
Studios many of you can probably relate
to this before the MCU films used to be
huge events and the writing for them was
always really good when you went to see
a Marvel film you expected it to be
amazing and more often than not they
were however today Marvel projects
aren't huge events because they happen
all the time and we have so much content
now that doesn't necessarily feel
important to the overall MCU or doesn't
feel like it connects to the overall MCU
it makes you feel like you don't have to
watch everything that comes out so when
you go into yet another show that you
may not be the most excited about and
then you see that it's very poorly
written you get discouraged and maybe
start to think and ask yourself is
Marvel failing and the answer is no not
overall at least Guardians of the Galaxy
3 and Loki season 2 proved Marvel still
has that Marvel spark and actually both
of these films succeeded because of the
writing here's the thing though the
writing was done in a very specific way
it was finished before they filmed this
is the main problem the Variety article
talked about how the writing team and
the VFX team were forced to work on
rewrites and reshoots really close to
the deadline of the movies or shows
being released they had to do all of
this after a lot was already shot for
some projects this is an issue and
Marvel has been doing it a lot we hear
about this frequently we hear about
re-shoot all the time in fact Marvel
just delayed a lot of projects why
re-shoot and rewrites this happens
because they don't lock down a great
script beforehand and then they have to
go back ReRe reshoot redo the V effects
and when that happens and you don't have
a lot of time with deadlines approaching
the movie or the show ends up messy and
bad with bad VFX however the two recent
massive successes from Marvel Studios
Loki season 2 and Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 both had finalized great
scripts before filming began this caused
everything to go smoothly and the
shooting to be done with ease and then
the VFX artist had had time to work on
what they got and make them great
because they weren't rushed to hit a
deadline because of re-shoot that's why
Loki looks fantastic everything that
goes on in Loki is amazing then we have
the Marvels which I didn't enjoy as much
as I really wanted to and that's because
honestly the story was kind of
everywhere the writing just wasn't that
good to me it had some great Parts in it
don't get me wrong but there really
lacked a solid plot the plot was kind of
weak and I really just didn't feel much
for the villain at all and of course the
movie just wasn't as big as Marvel made
it out to be and they overhyped it
because they knew it wasn't exactly
going to be amazing if you loved it
fantastic I'm super happy for you I wish
I did I however don't think it's as bad
as some people are stating but what do
we know about the Marvels it underwent a
lot of re-shoot because they kept
changing the story so again going back
to not having solid writing then when
you do rewrites you get re-shoot and the
vfxs have to be redone and it just
causes a lot of problems so if they just
homeone in and focused on writing good
scripts from the very beginning it
really would fix almost everything and
the good thing is Marvel knows what the
problem is bad stories and then too much
content which in turn produces more bad
stories they know this and they are
addressing it now in fact yesterday The
Hollywood Reporter did an article about
this with the title Marvel Studios
taking stock of strategy amid the
Marvel's meltdown yes we get it the
Marvel's isn't doing that well at the
box office but come on did anybody
really expect it to do phenomenal it had
a lot going against it that
unfortunately was not its own fault like
all of the strikes that went down the
cast couldn't even promote the film but
they do go on to talk about Marvel's new
strategy they state that Kevin and
Bob Iger have already said that they are
going to be scaling back a bit which is
good we've heard this already but they
also go on to talk about the recent
delays if you haven't heard Deadpool 3
is the only film that we are going to be
getting from Marvel in 2024 last
Thursday Marvel Studios announced that
they delayed Captain America New World
Order blade and the Thunderbolts and
according to the Hollywood Reporter this
is for a very specific reason and
although the production being shut down
for these is a part of the reason it
isn't the only reason according to the
Hollywood Reporter they delayed these so
they could basically write a better
script and do re-shoot for movies that
have already been shot AKA writing
better scenes basically they're taking
more time to work on the script it's
also ironic that Deadpool 3 is the only
one who stuck because Ryan Reynolds was
personally involved with the writing he
wrote most of it himself yes he did have
help of course but you knew Ryan
Reynolds wasn't going to let this script
be bad especially when you have Hugh
Jackman and Shawn Levy there with him so
no surprise here that the one movie that
probably has the best writing is the one
who's stuck to its date plus of course
you know Marvel Studios need something
to come out in 2024 but this is good
news it sucks that there are delays but
if they're going to make them better by
fixing the scripts by fixing the writing
awesome too bad they didn't do that
before they started everything but
Marvel Studios knows going forward this
is their biggest issue and if they fix
this then they can bounce back super
quickly this combined with what they've
already said they're going to do them
scaling back a little bit making these
MCU projects feel like big events once
again important events well that will
Revitalize the MCU and I think Marvel
Studios is just about to do that fingers
crossed but go ahead and let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below how have you
perceived the writing recently from the
Marvel Studios shows and movies let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the MCU
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof